this video is brought to you by mine
what's up wisecrack michael here when
searching for a video on youtube you may
have seen
this or maybe you've heard about the
copyright held twitch streamers have
recently been facing
copyright claims in legal battles are
everywhere
from record label suing youtubers to
youtubers suing television executives to
the entire music industry threatening to
sue twitch for doing such a bad job
monitoring music copyright claims over
the past 20 or so years
there have been so many copyright cases
that congress actually created a small
claims court for people to duke it out
over intellectual property and
even worked it into the second coveted
stimulus bill so it's worth asking
a couple questions here first how did we
get here and second is our current set
of copyright laws good or bad and for
who
so join us as we try to figure it all
out while getting increasingly angry at
disney
in this wisecrack edition on copyright
what went wrong
while the average person will probably
never have to battle a huge corporation
over a copyright claim
there are plenty of other reasons we
should be mindful of our relationships
with big businesses when you shop online
or sign up for a service your financial
and personal data can be stored by
companies without you having
any control over it this week's sponsor
mine can help you reclaim that
information
saving it from a potential data breach
the process is quick and simple
once you sign up using your email you
can see an overview of how many
companies are holding your information
i personally had 256 companies listed
which is crazy
because i can't even name 256 companies
mine
then shows you your footprint where you
can see each individual company that
holds your data and what type of service
they are if you click
see more you can see how often you use
the service the potential risk of a
security breach
and what type of info it has access to
this one has access to my financial info
and with data breaches being
a far too common occurrence i don't want
sensitive data to be stored unless
absolutely necessary from there you can
request to reclaim your data and it's as
simple as that you can visit your
reclaims at any time to review the
messages you sent see their status or
to cancel a request take control of who
has your information by looking into
mine today click the link in the
description to check it out
now back to the show now one of the
reasons copyright is so
interesting is because it creates an
inherent conflict on one end it protects
your creative work from being ripped off
and sold by others let me see
hello lawsuit but on the other hand it
can actively stifle people from remixing
or reacting to other creative work in a
way that's entertaining
and we can understand that conflict best
by looking at the man whose company
basically created our modern
intellectual property landscape
walt disney see in 1928 walt created the
character oswald the lucky rabbit for
universal studios
oswald was a huge hit but when disney
approached universal about making more
oswald cartoons he found out that the
studio was already working on new oswald
shorts without him
and because they own the rights he
couldn't do anything about it
walt walked away fuming and without the
rights to this adorable bunny
it was then that disney vowed to only
work for himself
and that he would own exclusive
copyright to all the characters
he and his company created and now
disney owns the copyright to uh
basically every character any of us have
cared about for the past 30 years
so way to be walt anyway as the story
goes in a fit of rage on his train ride
home
disney developed a brand new character
that would belong to him
and him alone mickey mother mouse
and despite some inexplicable sartorial
choices
mickey was an unprecedented success
being in control of his own intellectual
property
disney did what copyright laws should
encourage he made more mickey mouse
stuff
and that worked out pretty well for him
and examples of copyright gone right
are everywhere in 1990 for instance
screenwriter art buckwald
sued paramount pictures for stealing his
idea and turning it into coming to
america
he won the lawsuit and then settled with
paramount for nine hundred thousand
dollars
which was probably in their budget after
the film brought in
288 million dollars and if someone takes
your song and just repost it on youtube
you can either get the ad money from it
or
block it entirely and that's probably a
good thing
so while copyrights have been super
useful for many creators
these days it seems like it has a dark
side that is so much stuff is protected
by that
sea in a circle that a lot of folks
think it's stifling creativity
and making it impossible for artists to
create new work derived from or inspired
by
existing culture to get back to walt not
only is he an example of why protecting
your creative work is important
he's also an incredible example of the
perils of copyrighting things to
eternity
see in 1937 disney released his first
feature feature-length animated film
based on a story entirely concocted by
his big beautiful brain
which is definitely not frozen in a vet
hidden beneath the pirates of the
caribbean ride at disneyland
sure maybe i'm joking the story of snow
white was totally taken from the
brothers grimm
who themselves got all their stories by
traversing the german countryside
interviewing grandmas about how to scare
kids
he takes his great sharp scissors out
and then cuts their thumbs
clean off dwight white it's not just
snow white the disney company for
all its aggressive copyright enforcement
a berkeley school has been ordered to
pay up for
playing a disney movie at a children's
event
just loves borrowing other people's
stories from the public domain
meaning they're not copyrighted and are
free to use for example
mulan was based on a chinese legend the
little mermaid on a han's christian
anderson story
the jungle book on rudyard kipling's
characters and the list goes on
and on this isn't necessarily bad but
here's the grift
when disney pulls from the public domain
to make a movie they then
copyright their story and characters
making it nearly impossible for the next
storyteller to pull from the same
influences
try writing the next little mermaid and
you'll see what we mean but don't expect
us to pay your legal fees
but arguments over intellectual property
are way older than mickey mouse in fact
copyright disputes outdate the printing
press in his epigrams the ancient roman
poet marshall complained about receiving
no profit from the booksellers who
peddled his popular poems
and in 6th century ireland a literal
battle that cost
3 000 lives was fought over a dispute
about a copied manuscript
but copyright laws didn't develop just
to settle disputes in court and without
bloodshed
we sampled them from them but it's not
the same baseline
uh like it goes
that's the way theirs goes
change they were also seen as a way to
incentivize people to keep churning out
exciting new work and boy was that a
success
welcome to the space change
okay but intellectual property orgy with
basketballs aside
we do want to encourage the guy who made
beethoven to make that
as well as beethoven's second and third
and
fourth and fifth big paw plus big break
a christmas adventure and treasure trail
and this is exactly what the founding
fathers had in mind when they baked
copyright law into the constitution
like a lot of things in this wrinkly old
scroll the clause wasn't super specific
but it clearly indicated that congress
could use copyright restrictions to
incentivize writers and scientists to
create original works
it reads congress shall have power to
promote the progress of science and
useful arts by securing for limited
times to authors and inventors the
exclusive
right to their respective writings and
discoveries laws enacted under the
copyright clause created
limited monopolies that is monopolies
which give authors a good run
but don't last forever early policies
were deeply informed by a utilitarian
theory of property ownership
the idea is inventors and authors should
be rewarded proportionally to how useful
their creation is to consumers
and also that people make more useful
stuff when they don't have to worry
about people stealing it
of course the logic behind this isn't
exactly perfect
it's kind of like arguing that if disney
wasn't able to copyright his own work
he would have been too lazy to create
anything ever again
and maybe that's true but as anyone
who's gone to a show at denny's nose
not every artist is in it for the money
still english philosopher jeremy bentham
argued the copyright laws incentivize
inventors to make cool
stuff by offering them a monopoly on the
profits
he wrote that without the assistance of
the laws the inventor would almost
always be driven out of the market by
his rival
who finding himself without any expense
in possession of a discovery which has
cost the inventor much time and expense
would be able to deprive him of all his
deserved advantages by selling at a
lower price
this all seems pretty reasonable
incentivize talented and smart people to
make things by giving them the exclusive
ability to profit off their idea
and then once they've milked that little
eureka moment for a long time or you
know
die it goes into the public domain so
someone else can riff on it
what i'm saying is if you ask the
framers of the constitution if dr
seuss's kid should be able to make money
off of cartoons adapted from his books
30 years after his death my guess is
they'd say
nah but seuss's estate does still
control and profit off of all sales of
his books and all derivative content
and because the zeus is still control
what can be done with suicide p
we can't enjoy the star trek dr seuss
mashup book the
masses were begging for so what the fly
happened
here's the thing until the early 1830s
copyright terms only lasted 14 years
and even by the time disney created
mickey mouse copyright only lasted 28
years with an option to renew for
another 28 years
that would have meant mickey mouse would
have become public domain in 1984
but not so fast in 1976
congress gave the copyright act a
complete overhaul
with some guidance from a team of disney
lobbyists
see walt was dead his head was again not
frozen and stored beneath the pirates of
the caribbean ride in disneyland
and the company's copyright on their
iconic character was set to expire soon
they weren't too crazy about losing
ownership of their coveted revenue
generating glove enthusiast
the resulting 1976 act increased the
term of copyright protection from 28
years
to the life of the author plus 50 years
all in all the lobbying efforts of
disney and other corporations kept
mickey locked up in cinderella's castle
until 2003.
goofy pluto and donald also got their
disney prison sentences
extended and it also became way easier
to get sued for selling a crocheted
pattern of them sitting in disney jail
which i've i've never visited but
universal jail
you know and if you haven't noticed
mickey mouse is still
not in the public domain that's because
in 1998 the copyright term
extension act or ctea was passed
again extending works for 70 years after
the author's death and
also protecting corporate works for 95
years from their original publication or
120 years from their creation whichever
expires first
which means flow won't be public
property until like
2125 so guess that makes that screenplay
i wrote illegal
anyway people literally call this law
the mickey mouse protection act because
duh according to legal scholar lori
richter
disney spent 6.3 million dollars
lobbying for the extension they even set
up a political action committee
the disney pack and donated to senators
who would eventually sponsor the ctea
this was coupled with lobbying efforts
from other folks like musician george
gershwin's estate which was and still is
very concerned that gershwin musicals
might be sampled in rap music
okay dude this all resulted in yet
another extension for mickey as well as
a handful of other characters
that would have been in the public
domain by now but maybe you're thinking
so what if disney wants to keep control
of its characters well
one criticism is that disney is keeping
control of characters adapted from the
public domain and
that's really bad for art poo snow white
the little mermaid cinderella allied in
hercules sleeping beauty
mulan they were all taken from works
that were in the public domain which
means they
were available to the public and were
not protected by copyright
sure nowadays you could try to make your
own version of mulan but
barring the rare exception it's
remarkably hard to have much success
when a multinational corporation has a
virtual monopoly on the characters
you're creating and
the story you're telling that said you
can certainly try
mockbusters aside a bigger issue than
disney raiding the public domain
while contributing nothing to it is that
the copyright extensions they lobbied
for have made hundreds of thousands of
lesser-known works
completely unavailable and inaccessible
they just sit there
copyrights extended companies holding on
to them to maybe one day turn them into
something
who knows what creative derivative work
might have come from them
after all great works ranging from
gurtha's faust to west side story
were also derivatives of other stories
many scholars feel that copyright
extension well beyond an author's death
is far from utilitarian increases in
copyright protection can actually harm
the public more than they benefit
authors
especially when those authors are dead
and definitely not
frozen beneath the pirate ride and the
new authors are multinational
corporations
one argument lobbyist and copyright
enthusiasts use is something called
the tragedy of the commons argument
coined by garrett hardin in 1968
the tragedy of the commons stipulates
that open shared access to a resource
would cause
overuse and destruction of that resource
so
like open farmland an idea being open
and shareable
will only be harmful but research shows
that copyright correlates more with the
disappearance of
works than with their availability to
the masses in his study how copyright
keeps works disappeared
scholar paul heald analyzed large
samples of both amazon books and songs
and found that shortly after works are
created
and propertized they tend to disappear
from public view
only to reappear in significantly
increased numbers when they fall into
the public domain and
lose their owners like cow marvel is
totally sitting on countless forgotten
villains and heroes who may never return
to print or make it to the big screens
or how there hasn't been a movie yet
about namor the king of atlantis
because of copyright disputes between
marvel and universal
another legal scholar michael heller
calls this the tragedy of the
anti-commons
heller argues that while privatizing a
commons might stop
wasteful overuse it can also cause
wasteful under use
that is to say when everything is
copyrighted and the landscape becomes so
fragmented
it becomes very difficult to make
something new the public can't access
these things but competitive copyright
owners don't collaborate with each other
either
it might be helpful to think about the
public domain as a warehouse of ideas
which authors can reuse
sample change and incorporate into other
works if the warehouse isn't well
stocked
people don't have pre-existing cultural
materials to work
from some of europe's most well-regarded
composers wrote incredible pieces by
freely cribbing music that no one
particularly
owned and take this little tune you
might remember from the lion king
it comes from an old church gregorian
chant that would also make its way into
a famous piece by mozart and then hector
barely owes
another by franz liszt
[Music]
and then another by gustav holst
[Music]
and then the sweeney todd musical
[Music]
and a jethro tall track
that is to say ideas spreading freely is
often but not always
a very good thing but the real tragedy
is that another warehouse of ideas is
fully stocked
but no one's allowed in there except the
owner who checks in like
once every 20 years the one saving grace
that
sometimes lets us breach the
anti-commons at least in art and media
is something called fair use it permits
the use of unlicensed copyrighted work
under certain circumstances
like parody education commentary and
criticism
it's how wisecrack gets away with
showing clips from lots of movies and tv
shows
without getting sued so far the
underlying argument for fair use
is as utilitarian as jeremy bentham's
position on copyright
types of reuse under fair use are
allowed because they benefit the public
as a whole
and they don't hurt the original creator
in any measurable way
the downside of fair use is that it's a
legal defense
that means that if you want to fight a
copyright strike by claiming fair use
you have to go to court unless the owner
backs down
there everything is evaluated under a
complicated set of criteria
how much of the copyrighted work is used
what is its effect on the market
how much is it transformed going to
court may or may not be worth it for
either party involved but in some cases
it's probably better than paying
unaffordable licensing fees to studios
having anti-commons doesn't just mean
that we never see character crossovers
from competing
companies anymore it's way scarier than
that because intellectual property
isn't just art and books and media it's
also things like
drug patents heller gives the example of
a drug company that found a potential
treatment for alzheimer's disease
in order to develop it they needed
access to dozens of other patents
the owners of those patents demanded
exorbitant sums of money and some even
blocked the whole deal
the company was never able to get access
to the patents the drug
which might have saved millions of lives
sits on a shelf
it kind of seems like all these patents
and intellectual property rights are not
benefiting the public between terrifying
stories like that and artists feeling
smothered by giant corporations that own
everything it's not surprising that a
host of groups have popped up
advocating for changes ranging from the
elimination of bio patents to the
legalization of peer-to-peer file
sharing
these include creative commons which
advocates for more flexible and open
copyright laws so that creators don't
have to resort to fair use as a defense
others argue for the complete abolition
of copyright laws and encourage creative
piracy until those laws
change groups like the league of noble
peers promote the movement against
intellectual property while pirate
cinema
literally screens movies without
licensing them meanwhile
mickey mouse is set to enter the public
domain in 2024
the jury's still out on if disney
lobbyists will convince congress to
extend copyright terms again
hopefully they won't and we can finally
release our limited edition mickey
jailbreak merch
but what do you guys think should we
abolish copyright altogether
or change the laws to give a little more
flexibility to creators and artists
let us know in the comments big thanks
to our incredible patrons
slam that subscribe button like your
mickey mouse trying to break out of the
patent office and don't forget to ring
that bell
and as always thanks for watching later
[Music]
you